-I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
If you answer them correctly,
you will win
a golden retriever puppy.
If you answer incorrectly,
your opponent will receive
the puppy.
Most puppies at the end of the
game is the Pup Quiz champion.
♪♪
Tracy, you're our guest,
so we shall commence with you.
The first question is...
Is it, "A," green anaconda;
"B," king cobra,
or "C," reticulated python?
What do you think, Tracy?
-I think you would know this
'cause you probably
have a snake.
-You have snakes.
You love snakes.
[ Clock ticking ]
-Reticulated.
-Reticulated python, "C"?
-Yes.
-Let's see what the answer is.
You are correct!
Reticulated python!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Gimme.
-You get Gary Frick Jr.
-Yes, baby. Yes, baby.
[ Laughter, dog barking ]
-Next question is to you, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-Which of these birds
is native
to the island of New Guinea?
-What?!
-Is it, "A" --
-He got "longest snake"!
-"A," the singing bushlark.
-That sounds fake.
-"B," painted berrypecker.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't know Barry was
into that. Or "C" --
-That's the longest species
of snake, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
-You ever met Barry before?
-Never.
Buff-rumped warbler.
So, is it "A," "B," or "C"?
Singing bushlark...
-Alright, buff-rumped war--
Well, it couldn't be
"C" and "C."
That's the way I did my SATs.
I would just switch
to different things.
-And how'd you do on those?
-I got a...
610.
So, that's pretty good.
I'm gonna say, uh...
Gosh.
S--
Singing bushlark, "A."
-"A"? Ooh, no.
[ Buzzer sounds ]
It was painted berrypecker.
[ Laughter ]
-You're the worst, man.
-So, Jimmy, Tracy gets our
adorable puppy, Mary Kennedy.
-Aww! Mary Kennedy!
[ Dog barking, applause ]
-Yes.
-The score is 2 pups to 0.
[ Dog barking ]
Oh! That sounds means it's time
for Double Puppardy.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Questions are now worth
two puppies.
-Yes!
-And the next question
is for you, Tracy.
-I'm not even comfortable
in this seat.
-You look very comfortable.
-Ask him what's the --
what's the biggest snake.
-This is a hard one.
And I don't meant the answer
to the last question.
-What type of animal
does mohair come from?
"A," chinchilla;
"B," a goat;
or "C," sheep.
-What kind of hair?
-Mohair.
-Mohair?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Clock ticking ]
"A," chinchilla; "B", goat;
or "C," sheep?
-The one puppy's winking at me.
-I'm gonna go "B."
-"B," goat. You are correct!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tracy receives Kyle McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong.
Come on out, puppies!
-This is unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They're my babies.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Alright, Jimmy, next question
goes to you.
That's a calendar picture,
right there.
-Yeah.
-The golden retriever, Jimmy.
-Oh, yeah.
-Golden retriever --
-That's me, I have that.
-...was first bred
in the mid-1800s
by Lord Tweedmouth --
-What?
-...in what country?
Tweed. Tweedmouth.
-Yes, tweed.
-Lord Tweedmouth.
-Okay, yeah.
-Is it "A," Scotland;
"B," Canada;
or "C," New Zealand?
-Tweed --
I'm gonna say "A," Scotland.
-Yes, it is! Correct!
[ Bell dings ]
Roger Blain and Ted Mooney
go straight to Jimmy!
-Oh, no, no!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get that puppy. Get that puppy.
-Wait.
-You have it?
-Yeah.
[ Groans ] Come here, buddy.
-Thank you very much.
Hey, how are you?
-Ohh, come here.
Got Gary Frick?
That's Gary Frick, Jr.
-Let's go back to Tracy.
-Hi, guys.
-Sorry, that one got away.
Sorry, Tracy.
-There you go.
-We got too excited.
-I just need a pocketful
of Kibble 'n Bits.
-There we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, here we go.
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh, that sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
-This is where
all of your puppies
and all of your opponent's --
whoever gets this question
gets all of the puppies.
-Yes.
-Pick up the boards.
Pick up your markers to write
down the answer to this.
The Final Puppardy question.
[ Laughing ] And the answer,
for all of the puppies.
[ Laughter ]
How many quills does the average
porcupine have on its body?
You have 10 seconds,
starting now.
[ Clock ticking ]
Average porcupine.
Not a super quilly porcupine.
Average.
Not a bald porcupine.
Regular, everyday --
[ Buzzer sounds ]
Oh! Alrighty.
Jimmy, what did you write down?
-10,000?
[ Laughter ]
-10,000! Alright, Tracy.
What was your answer to
the question, how many quills?
-2 mill.
-2 mill!
The answer is 30,000.
Jimmy, you are
the Pup Quiz winner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't take it.
I can't take it.
I gotta give this one to my man.
Tracy Morgan.
I gotta give it to Tracy.
You're the real Pup Quiz champ,
my friend.
-Yes, Jim!
-My thanks to Tracy Morgan
and all these adorable puppies.
-I'll be asking both of you
animal trivia questions.
And if you answer them
correctly,
you win a golden retriever
puppy.
If you answer them incorrectly,
your opponent gets the pup.
-Mm-hmm.
-Jared, you're up first.
-Here we go.
-What -- This is a tough one.
Is he "A,"
American foxhound terrier?
-What?
-"B," Jack Russell terrier.
Or "C," beagle.
[ Clock ticking, audience
shouting answers ]
-Hmmm.
-No help from the audience,
please.
[ Ticking continues ]
American foxhound...
-"C."
-Yes, of course it's "C." Yes.
[ Bell dings ]
-This is an easy question.
-There you go.
Mr. Gary Frick Jr.
-Aww!
[ Speaking gibberish ]
-I love you, man.
[ Laughter ]
Don't talk down to him, Jared.
Yeah. Alright.
-Alright, next question
is for you, Jimmy.
-I hope it's as easy as
"what dog was Snoopy."
-Well, it's not.
[ Laughter ]
-Which one of these crustaceans
is known --
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
I got to name a crustacean.
-Yes.
-Which one of these crustaceans
is known for its brightly
colored, striped shell?
-Is it "A,"
the shame-faced crab?
-This is insane.
-"B," the fleshy prawn.
[ Laughter ]
Or "C," the elegant
squat lobster.
[ Laughter ]
This is for Mary Kennedy
the puppy.
-The elegant squat lobster?
-Yes.
-I don't know about that.
-♪ Squat lobster ♪
-Fleshy Prawn
was my Juggalo name.
-Yes. And your nickname.
[ Laughter ]
-Shame-faced crab.
-Shame-faced crab?
-What else are you
but shame-faced?
-I'm gonna say it's "B,"
fleshy prawn.
-Ooh! Wrong.
[ Buzzer sounds ]
-What?!
-It is the elegant
squat lobster.
Elegant squat lobster?!
-Jared gets our next puppy,
adorable Mary Kennedy!
-Of course.
-Wait, you knew that one?
You knew that one?
[ Laughter ]
-Aww!
-You knew elegant squat lobster?
-Of course!
Who doesn't know that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Elegant squat lobster.
-Oh!
-Aww. [ Speaking gibberish ]
[ Dog barking ]
-Did you hear that sound?
-Yes.
-That means it's time
for Double Puppardy.
-What's that mean?
-These questions are worth
two puppies.
Next question is for you, Jared.
-Aww.
-What? Are you kidding me?!
[ Laughter ]
This is totally insane.
I'll take this one.
-Are they white
with black stripes?
-What? This is so silly!
-Black with white stripes.
Or tan with
black and white stripes?
-This better be a trick question
or something.
[ Clock ticking ]
This is absolutely insane.
What color is a zebra?
-"C"!
-"A"?
No!
-What?
-They are black
with white stripes.
So, Jimmy, you get Kyle McAdams
and Lisa Armstrong!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-That was a barn burner!
-Hi! Hi!
-Aww!
-Aww, I was just trying
to fake Jared out.
Of course everyone knows
that zebras are black
with white stripes.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way,
you guys were no help.
[ Laughter ]
At all.
-Okay, next question
goes to Jimmy.
-Hi, buddy. Yeah.
-[ Speaking gibberish ]
-Okay, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-In 1997 -- remember that year?
-Oh, my God.
-Which one of these animals
was elected mayor
of an Alaska town?
Is it "A," Stubbs the Cat;
"B," Buzzwinkle the Moose...
-That sounds fake.
-or "C," Zero the Mountain Goat.
-In Alaska?
-Yes, for two puppies.
Roger Blain and Ted Mooney.
-Stubbs the Cat.
-Stubbs the Cat? Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
Jimmy, meet Roger Blain
and Ted Mooney!
-Thank you. These guys didn't
want to hear any cat...
They didn't want to hear
any cat trivia.
Oh, hi, guys.
-Aww!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Well, I'm in --
[ Dog barking ]
-Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa!
That sound means it's time
for Final Puppardy.
[ Laughter ]
-This one is for all of your
opponents' puppies
and the game.
-Alright.
-Okay, pick up the boards
and the markers next to you.
-Guys, you got to help me out
on this one, okay?
-Write down your answers
to this question.
Whoever's closer
to the correct answer...
[ Audience "aww"s ]
...is the Pup Quiz winner.
-[ Giggles ]
-Alright, you guys ready?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Roughly --
Roughly how many flowers --
-Pun intended.
[ Laughter ]
Ruff-ly.
[ Barks ] How many flowers
does a beehive have to harvest
to make one pound of honey?
You have 10 seconds,
starting now.
One pound of honey.
-Oh, my goodness.
-How many flowers does a bee--
-One pound?
-One pound of honey.
[ Buzzer sounds ]
Okay.
Jimmy, what did you write down?
Are you still writing?
Okay, you said 305 flowers.
[ Laughter ]
-305.
-That's how many bees --
That's how many --
to get one pound of honey,
you think bees have to go
to 305 flowers?
Okay, great.
Jared, what do you say?
-Oh, no.
-10,000?
-10 million!
He's saying 10 million flowers.
-10 million flowers?
So, actually, Jimmy, you win,
because it's 2 million.
-Yeah!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Yeah! Yeah!
Jimmy is the Pup Quiz winner!
-No, Jared can be
the Pup Quiz winner.
Why don't you bring these over
to Jared,
introduce him to these.
Our thanks to Jared Leto
and all these adorable puppies.